The Joe Rogan experience.
Oh,
you sober up and then they become
annoying and then they want to talk about
their sobriety.
I cannot stand,
can't say I'm recovering
addicts. They dropped me. Yeah,
man. They're worse than
people who just find yoga.
They just won't shut the fuck
up about recovery. Yeah. I, I'm,
I'm guilty of that with many things.
If I get into something,
I can't shut the fuck up about
it, but I get it, you know,
for them it's like this pivotal moment
in their life where all of a sudden they
have their shit together and they
just want to talk about all the time.
The thing that drives me nuts
though is when they judge, yes.
They always get a little judgey
that like, are you sure? Like,
do you need that last drink? And I'm
like, yeah, I do and I can handle my shit.
So maybe alone. Hey, I'm super sorry.
You got that fucked up gene. Yeah, yeah.
Whatever it is. You went too far with
it. But I've got it under control.
I like being a little buzzed like it.
And luckily the drugs in the,
in the drinking that I do, it's a,
you know, I, if I'm going to drink,
I drink high quality stuff,
uh, smoke a little weed,
but the other drugs don't really do it
for me to have you fucked with the other
drugs. What do we tried? Just about
everything. And it just like, not for me.
Like I've done cocaine and the next
day been like, I just feel stupid.
Like I feel like everything that came
into my mouth last night was dumb.
I feel like hell. Uh, I
enjoy, we'd chills me out a,
I like beer and wine and, and
uh, and vodka and whiskey.
I have not done a lot of things.
I've never done masculine
or pod. Just basically,
I think they're pretty much the same
thing. I've never done, um, coke.
I've never done meth.
I've never done any real in Pheta means.
I've been always been
scared of those though,
because those are the ones that I've
seen people like really lose their lives
for. Yes. And I don't mess with them. Fed
means at all and I don't enjoy it. Uh,
as someone who grinds their teeth,
you know, like that's, that's awful.
And I found like with comedy,
you can't be funny on cocaine
at comics who do do who do
cocaine and our flight. Yeah.
Because I just find it to be like,
you're not,
I can't laugh at anything
and I can't, like I'm talking
too fast. My timing's off.
Uh, and like, I'm not
thinking in a funny way,
but I've always been surprised to
comics who have coke problems. Yeah.
Joey Diaz talked about that, cause Joey
Diaz did coke for years, but he doesn't,
he's never done coke. And Gannon
said, she goes, I, he goes,
every time I tried it I was
fucking terrible. He goes,
it takes away your soul,
your heart. You've got no heart when
you up there. Yeah. You know, the,
I guess again, I've never done
it, but uh, what I get is just,
I get that whole speedy thing
where you just like your,
your sense of how people are perceiving
you as distorted timing is distorted.
Yeah. They got, I don't even go on stage
high. Oh Man, I have a couple of beers.
I don't want to be slurring. What if
I'd been smoking pot at all that day?
It's a worst show for it. Really? Yeah.
I wonder why that is. I think I'm just,
I'm just in my own head,
you know, and make,
it makes me want to get through the set
as opposed to being present and enjoying
it. Like I just want it to be over
so I can go chill out. You know?
I just interested in that
only on only with weed.
One of my favorite things to do when
I would take guys in the room with me,
he's get them so high that they could
barely talk and then put them on stage.
That's what I do. The first, the first
two guys I would open for on the road,
it was a Doug Benson and Brian
Posehn, Jesus Christ. They were like,
they wanted to smoke
all day that I was like,
every time I was a feature act like little
most every time I was a feature act,
I was terrible because I thought like,
I have to smoke. I've got this book.
These guys are,
they won't take me on the road,
but I'm like barely getting through
this half hour and I'm terrible.
It's not a smart move for someone who's
just getting going to be that high on
stage. But one time I did, I was, uh, I,
I really didn't smoke pot until I was 30,
like really smoke pot. But I did it a
handful of times when I was younger.
And one time when I was like a 21,
I was living with my buddy
Jimmy. And uh, him and his,
one of his friends came over and he had
pot and we smoked some pot during the
day.
I think we had a barbecue or something.
And then I had a gig like six hours later
I was still high and I remember being
on stage and,
and my timing was excellent and I was
so locked in and focused and I remember
being terrified that I was
going to be terrible. Terrified,
but I really nailed it for whatever
reason. But then I never did it again.
And I was like, Whoa, I
got away with it, you know?
And then I started smoking when I
was 30 and it Kinda changed my act.
Like it made my act from like,
it made my act more introspective.
I started talking about weird or subjects
and more interesting thing I thought I
started talking about things that
I was actually more interested in.
Did you start to write on stage more
when you were high on stage? Yeah,
I kind of always have written on
stage a little bit, but mostly, um,
mostly like tangents.
Like I'd go off on a weird branch if I
knew how to get back to the river, right.
Oh,
take like a weird stream off to the right.
And then just long as I knew how to get
back to the river of whatever the fuck I
was talking about, I'd be
fine. But when I'm high,
I'll just let go wandering
through the woods. Like I'm not,
I'm not even concerned about the
river. I'm like, you know, there,
there's the river of thought,
the pattern that you're following.
But when I'm high, I'm like, what?
Who the fuck wants that and why?
Why would you be that person?
And then I started thinking
like I remember when I was
a kid and then I'll just
like out of nowhere have this idea and
I'm hoping it's going to go somewhere.
And those moments I feel
like they're like, it's like
foraging for food.
Like occasionally you find it,
like if you go out looking for mushrooms,
you don't know where they are.
You might find edible mushrooms.
Hopefully you're going to find them.
Sometimes you won't. Sometimes you
come home with an empty basket,
but sometimes you get them and the only
way you find out is if your forage,
and that's kind of what it feels like
when I'm high on stage. It's like, okay,
but then I'm also really worried
that I'm going to be boring.
Like I want to beat,
I know these people paid to see.
I know I'm trying to develop material,
but I also know I'm entertaining
these people in the present.
So it's like a fine line.